the thing about this headline
that's really got my attention is
we're just in this place where like we
need to stop generalizing just in
general the generalizing thing is rough
you know like it's always focus groups
of one meaning everyone's life is
different this article talks about like
young people gen Z you're actually
excited about this is insane some of
them are excited to go to the office of
course some people are incredibly
extroverted even if they're 22 and not
47 and they enjoy the office life also a
lot of youngsters a ton of my young
employees are talking about wanting to
be back in the office because they want
to pick up on the osmosis that they heal
the 22 year olds are saying from the 27
year olds they hear that they learned a
lot by just being around people and
they're excited about that the bottom
line is of course there's a lot of young
people that want to do this of course
there's a bunch of old people that
believe in social media there's all
kinds the generalizing is boring